you
the glenohumeral joint is composed of
the humerus and scapula and is the most
mobile joint in the body the motion of
the humerus relative to the articular
surface of the scapula the glenoid is
described as spinning sliding and
rolling shoulder motion and stability is
achieved via the coordinated contraction
of the deltoid and rotator cuff the
deltoid is the largest muscle in the
shoulder it elevates the arm the deltoid
consists of three distinct heads
anterior middle and the posterior
the middle deltoid wraps around the
greater tuberosity to generate a
stabilizing compressive force the
rotator cuff is composed of four muscles
that generate the torque necessary for
rotation the anatomic arrangement of
these muscles generates humeral head
compression and glenoid centering at all
joint positions
muscles generate forces that are
converted to torques in proportion to
the perpendicular distance between the
joint center of rotation and the muscles
line of action this distance is the
muscles moment arm the larger the moment
arm the greater capacity for that muscle
to generate the torque required for
motion and support external loads the
location of the moment arm relative to
the center of rotation determines the
type of motion the muscle creates
shoulder muscles with lines of action
superior lateral to the center of
rotation generate abduction lines of
action inferior medial to the center of
rotation generate adduction lines of
action anterior to the center of
rotation generate internal rotation and
lines of action posterior to the center
of rotation generate external rotation
rotator cuff tears have negative
consequences on motion and stability as
the rotator cuff fails to balance the
deltoid the humeral head migrates
superiorly and impinges with the
acromion leading to further tearing dr.
Charles NIR coined the term cuff tear
arthropathy or CTA to describe this
arthritic eroded condition of the
glenohumeral joint following prolonged
subacromial compression
the standard of care for CTA is reverse
shoulder arthroplasty
the reverse shoulder prosthesis inverts
the anatomic articulation making the
glenoid convex and the humerus concave
inverting the concavities restore
stability by creating a fixed fulcrum
that prevents superior migration
facilitates the deltoids to elevate the
arm and limits motion to only spinning
inverting the concavities also causes an
inferior medial shift in the center of
rotation and position of the humerus
this dramatically alters the
relationship of each muscle relative to
its normal physiologic function medially
shifting the center of rotation
increases the length of the deltoid
abduction moment arms improving its
efficiency to elevate the arm
however medially shifting the humerus
shortens the rotator cuff muscles which
has negative consequences on rotational
strength and motion and leads to
impingement of the humerus with a
scapular neck known as scapular notching
inferior li shifting the center of
rotation and humerus along gates the
deltoid deltoid elongation improves
muscle tone and has been suggested to
increase strength and joint stability
however deltoid elongation modifies the
normal contour decreases wrapping around
the greater tuberosity and creates
cosmetic concerns
excessive deltoid elongation may lead to
acromial stress fractures
inferior li shifting the humerus alters
the subscapularis and infraspinatus line
of action increasing their adduction
capability at low elevations
counteracting the work of the deltoid
different prosthesis design parameters
impact how the center of rotation and
position of the humerus change relative
to the anatomic shoulder
the groom on Traverse shoulder Glennis
fear whose thickness is 1/2 its diameter
media Liza's the center of rotation to
the face of the glenoid to minimize the
torque on the glenoid bone implant
interface and increase the deltoid
abductor moment arm lengths the Grammont
humeral prostheses has a 155° humeral
neck angle and is placed within the
humerus causing it to shift medially and
be placed directly inferior to the
Glenna sphere which along gates the
deltoid butt shortens the rotator cuff
this implant design and resulting
humeral positioning is effective at
restoring active abduction and forward
flexion but is less effective at
restoring active rotation Vermont's
medial positioning is also responsible
for a low glenoid loosening rate but a
high scapular notching rate
prosthesis designs that lateral eyes the
center of rotation relative to the
grommet may improve active rotation
strength and stability and also reduce
the scapular notching rate lateral izing
the center of rotation lateral eise's
the humerus which tensions the remaining
rotator cuff muscles and minimizes
humeral impingement with the scapular
neck
however lateral izing the center of
rotation increases the torque on the
glenoid fixation surface and decreases
the length of the deltoid abductor
moment arms because the deltoid moment
arms are decreased as the center of
rotation is lateralized the deltoid
becomes less efficient and requires a
greater force to elevate the arm these
elevated loads have negative
implications on rehabilitation muscle
fatigue stress fractures and prosthesis
fixation alternative prosthesis designs
are available that lateralized the
humerus without lateral izing the center
of rotation doing so better restores
rotator cuff muscle tension while
maintaining remnants deltoid moment arm
lengths and minimizing the torque on the
glenoid implant bone interface the
humerus can be lateralized to also
minimize scapular notching by decreasing
the grommet humeral neck angle of 155
degrees proportionally increasing the
grommet Glenna sphere diameter and
thickness of 36 by 18 millimeters
decreasing the humeral liner constraint
and by increasing the medial offset of
the humeral prosthesis increasing the
humeral liner stem offset increases the
deltoid abductor moment arm lengths to
improve joint efficiency and increases
deltoid wrapping to improve stability
next generation implant systems achieve
this increased offset by placing the
liner on top of the resected surface
instead of within the humerus doing so
permits the same humeral stem for both
anatomic and reverse shoulder
arthroplasty improving the ease of
revisions and reducing the overall cost
by retaining the same implant
repair of the subscapularis with
anatomic shoulder arthroplasty is
critical
restoring the transverse force couple
created by the subscapularis and
posterior rotator cuff is essential for
stability however the combined force
generated by these opposing muscles
increases the joint reaction force with
reverse shoulder arthroplasty as the
subscapularis functions as an adductor
its line of action opposes the deltoid
requiring the deltoid to work more for a
given motion when the subscapularis is
repaired
however subscapularis repair may not be
necessary for stability for alternative
prosthesis designs that lateral eyes the
humerus more thus recommendations for
subscapularis repair are not universally
applicable to all reverse shoulder
designs the requirement for repair is
dependent upon humeral positioning not
repairing the subscapularis with
lateralized humeral designs may reduce
the force required by the deltoid and
reduce the overall joint reaction force
since the subscapularis no longer
functions as an adductor
glenoid implant positioning alters
reverse shoulder biomechanics inferior
glenoid placement is recommended to
achieve Glenna sphere overhang and avoid
scapular notching however inferior
glenoid placement further shifts the
center of rotation and position of the
humerus
this further along gates the deltoid
reduces deltoid wrapping and may also
increase the risk of acromial stress
fractures
using reverse shoulders in eroded
glenoid media Liza's the joint line
further shortens the rotator cuff and
further reduces deltoid wrapping
excessive joint medialization can
completely eliminate deltoid wrapping
and cause the deltoid to generate a
distraction force
when using rivers shoulders and medially
worn glenoid the joint line should be
lateralized with bone graft or by using
thicker Glenna spheres
when using reverse shoulders in
superiorly worn glenoid the joint line
should be lateralized with superior
augmented implants
when using reverse shoulders in
posterior lis worn glenoid the joint
line should be lateralized with
posterior augmented implants
you